12.07.62.
Okay, klar.
Und Frau Berger, wissen Sie schon, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Das weiß ich leider zu gut hin und wieder wiege ich mich ja mal. Ich wiege 84 Kilo.
84, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie letztlich?
Also in meinem Ausweis steht immer noch 164. Ich glaube, das stimmt auch noch.
164. Okay.
Frau Berger, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also das geht eigentlich jetzt nicht erst seit heute so, aber ich hab seit Wochen eigentlich dieses Gefühl,
dass ich so keine Luft kriege, wenn ich zum Beispiel die Treppe hochlaufe.
Okay.
Dann kriege ich nicht gut Luft und dann hab ich so das Gefühl, dass es so in der Brust ganz eng wird.
Und ja, jetzt hab ich schon seit einiger Zeit mir angewöhnt, dass ich tatsächlich auch noch ein dickes,
zweites Kissen in mein Bett lege, weil ich auch nachts das Gefühl hab, ich kann gar nicht so gut schlafen.
Wenn ich so flach liege. Aber diese Atemnot, wenn man sich auch nur ein bisschen anstrengt,
was wenn ich meine Einkaufstasche die Treppe hoch trage, dann denke ich schon, boah,
ich komm gar nicht mehr hier oben an. Das ist ja furchtbar anstrengend, ja.
Okay. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, ob diese Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten sind.
Ja, plötzlich wahrscheinlich nicht. Also ich denke schon, ja, irgendwann hab ich's halt gemerkt,
dass das immer schlechter wird, ja.
Okay.
Und ja, haben Sie schon gesagt, beim Treppe steigen oder Einkaufstasche tragen?
Ja, also dann ist es besonders schlimm, ne?
Ja. Und auch in der Ruhe fühlen Sie sich diese Beschwerden?
Na, wie gesagt, beim Schlafen kann ich nicht so gut flach liegen.
Aber normalerweise, wenn ich ganz ruhig bin, hab ich natürlich eigentlich jetzt so keine Atemnot.
Nee, dann kenn ich das nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden? Sie nennen Wochen, aber wie viele Wochen meinen Sie?
Boah, also bestimmt so anderthalb Monate, fast zwei Monate.
Ja.
Ich würd sagen so sechs, sieben Wochen oder so.
Da hat das angefangen. Erst hab ich auch gedacht, das hängt vielleicht mit dem Wetter zusammen,
mit der Wärme, aber auch jetzt, wo es ein bisschen kühler ist, geht's mir auch nicht besser.
Also es ist irgendwie doof.
Okay. Frau Berger, diese Beschwerden immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg sind?
Ja, in Ruhe hab ich eigentlich diese Enge nicht, ne? Hab ich das nicht.
Ja, es kann attackenartig beim Belastung besonders und beim Himmlegen.
Ja, so kann man das vielleicht sagen, ja.
Okay.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, also gerade wenn ich jetzt ein Stückchen mehr laufe oder in der zweiten Treppe oder so,
da merk ich eben auch, dass ich nicht nur so luftnötig bin,
sondern manchmal muss ich mich dann auch am Treppengeländer festhalten, weil ich das Gefühl hab, boah, mir ist ganz schwindelig, ja?
Ja.
Oder auch beim, ja, so als es jetzt so heiß war auf der Straße, hab ich dann manchmal gesagt, boah, jetzt musst du mal stehen bleiben,
weiß gar nicht mehr so genau, wie du geradeaus läufst, ne? Das war ganz unangenehm.
Ja, natürlich, das ist unangenehm. Ich hab das auch, natürlich.
Und leider sind wir uns halt dabei, bewusst schmerzen, heißt rasen, heißt klopfen.
Das hab ich jetzt nicht so, ich hab nur das Gefühl, dass es sich so eng anfühlt in der Brust.
Okay, nur enge Kette.
Mhm.
Okay. Und, ja, Frau Berger, momentan hat sie auch diese Beschwerden?
Im Augenblick? Nee, jetzt sitz ich ja hier ganz ruhig, da hab ich nix.
Okay.
Ich bin zurzeit eher so ein bisschen schlapp und müde. Ich merk, dass ich nicht so frisch bin und, ja, dass ich schnell einschlafe,
was weiß ich, wenn ich im Sessel sitze oder so, dass ich dann so einnicke, dass mir die Augen zufallen, ne?
Okay. Und Frau Berger, leiden Sie unter auf Fieber, Katschweiß, Nachtschweiß?
In Fieber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht. Also ich hab natürlich jetzt geschwitzt, als es so heiß war.
Ja.
Also, ja, in meiner Wohnung, da muss ich auch, also ich wohne dann ziemlich weit oben, ich musste ziemlich viel Treppen laufen.
Und oben ist es halt immer warm in den Häusern, ja? Also bei mir war es schon jetzt ziemlich heiß, da hab ich natürlich geschwitzt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gesporene, gerotete, gewarmen, erwärmte Beine?
Ja, dass meine Beine geschwollen sind, das ist mir aufgefallen. Das hab ich aber eigentlich auch so auf die Wärme geschoben.
Und hab mir gedacht, na ja, so bei so Hitze hat man ja leicht mal geschwollene Füße.
Okay. Und seit wann haben Sie diese Beine Probleme?
Ja, das ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, als es so heiß wurde, also in den letzten vier Wochen, würde ich sagen.
Okay, letzten vier Wochen.
Also da hab ich richtig, wenn ich Socken anhatte, hab ich richtig so einen Schnürrand oder auch wenn ich Sandalen anhatte, als es so heiß war,
hat man richtig gesehen, wo die Riemen von den Sandalen gelaufen sind.
Okay.
Diese Beinbeschwerde ist beidseitig oder einseitig?
Beidseitig.
Nee, da sind beide Füße gleich.
Beide Füße.
Und morgen ist es dann auch wieder besser eigentlich.
Also wenn ich Gelegenheit hab, dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Okay. Bemerkern Sie ein bisschen bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beinschmerzen oder geschwollene Beine?
Ja, ich denke halt, wenn ich die Füße unten hab und wenn es so warm ist.
Okay.
Ja, und Frau Belker, haben Sie auch Grippen, Tafelgefühl, Lähmungen in Ihren Beinen?
Nein, nein, das mit den Beinen, das ist ja nur so jetzt, dass die ein bisschen dick sind.
Sonst hab ich da keine Beschwerden.
Okay, und haben Sie dabei Hüsten beispielsweise?
Was hab ich?
Hüsten oder Brustschmerzen?
Hüsten hab ich morgens vor allem, wenn ich aufwache.
Da muss ich immer erstmal ordentlich abhusten.
Seit langem Jahr haben Sie morgendliche Hüste?
Ja, ist mir jetzt auch in letzter Zeit erst aufgefallen.
Okay, ja.
Rester Zeit, okay.
Ist dieser Hüsten trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Eigentlich ist der eher trocken.
Ich hab immer das Gefühl, da müsste was kommen, aber es kommt eigentlich nichts.
Okay, okay.
Und Frau Belker, bleiben Sie unter Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Appetitlosigkeit?
Geschmecken tut es mir eigentlich sehr gut.
Ich hab auch schon wieder ein bisschen zugenommen.
Aber Übelkeit, also wie gesagt, wenn es gerade so schlecht ist mit der Luft und
mit dem Schwinde, dann ist das so an der Grenze zur Übelkeit.
Aber eigentlich, das ist nicht mein Hauptproblem, nee.
Okay.
Und haben Sie dabei Schwindel, Kopfschmerzen, Bewusstsein verloren?
Bewusstsein verloren?
Nicht, aber dieser Schwindel, das hab ich Ihnen ja beschrieben, ne.
Dass ich dann das Gefühl hab, ich muss mich festhalten, weil mir so alles dreht, ne.
Okay, okay.
Wie im Kreiszeil, ja?
Ja, so wie im Karussell so ein bisschen, ne.
Okay, okay.
Frau Belker, haben Sie ungewollte Gewichtveränderungen in letzter Zeit?
Ja, ich hab zwei, fast drei Kilo zugenommen, das gefällt mir gar nicht.
Ich wiege ja schon ganz schön viel.
Drei Kilo, ja.
Und Frau Belker, seit wann sind Sie in meiner Pause?
Och Gott, das ist schon lange.
Bestimmt etwas über zehn Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Und besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Vormarkt?
Ja, zu dieser Krebsvorsorge geh ich regelmäßig hin, ja.
Und leiden Sie unter Stuhlgang oder was alles, sind Probleme?
Also nachts muss ich wohl manchmal auf die Toilette, das ist schon ein bisschen ein Problem, ja.
Aber sonst kann ich an mich nicht beklagen.
Ja, wie gesagt, deswegen schlafe ich dann nicht so gut, ne, weil ich dann nachts mal raus muss, ne.
Aber eigentlich so mit Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang habe ich so zum Glück keine Probleme.
Okay, super.
Und haben Sie schon irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen, beispielsweise Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, Bluthochdruck, das hat man vor drei Jahren oder so festgestellt.
Da hat man auch gemerkt, dass diese Fette im Blut, dass die auch ein bisschen hoch sind.
Okay.
Ja, und dann...
Haben Sie schon erinnern, wie war Ihr letzter Kontroll, Blutverdreiter?
Boah, das kann ich Ihnen nicht mehr sagen, das kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Okay, und Ihnen ist die Bluthochdruck gut eingestellt?
Ja, ich nehme alle möglichen Tabletten, ich weiß gar nicht, wofür ist.
Also ich habe da inzwischen so eine ganze Liste.
Messen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Blutdruck?
Also ich messe den selber nicht, aber wenn ich beim Arzt bin, dann wird der gemessen und...
Ja, manchmal, wenn ich bei meiner einen Tochter bin, die hat so ein Blutdruckgerät,
dann messe ich den auch hin und wieder mal, aber ich selber messe den nicht.
Ja, aber Frau Berger, ich empfehle Ihnen, ein Blutdruckmessgerät bekommen und regelmäßig kontrollieren.
Ja, das macht man sicher, aber auch nur verrückt damit, oder?
Um Ihre Gesundheit zu schönen.
Ansonsten haben Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Ja, also vor sieben Jahren hatte ich mal was Blödes, da war die Bauchspeicheldrüse entzündet,
das war sehr unangenehm.
Das war auch dann so ein Grund, dass ich dann irgendwann gesagt habe,
dass ich nicht mehr gut arbeiten kann, oder habe ich mich wirklich sehr schlecht gefühlt.
Ja, und jetzt kürzlich war ich mal bei meinem Hausarzt und da hat er mal so ein EKG gemacht
und da hat er gesagt, ich hätte so was mit Flimmern.
Ah, also Probleme.
Ja, und seitdem nehme ich immer so was, was die Blutgerinnung, was die so ein bisschen hemmt.
Das ist Makuma.
Ich nehme Makuma, aber immer nur eine halbe Tablette und die nehme ich immer abend
und da muss ich eben auch häufiger zu meinem Doktor und der kontrolliert dann, ob das gut ist.
Okay, und nehmen Sie regelmäßig noch andere Tabletten ein oder bei mir?
Ja, also ich habe hier mal eine Liste, die kann ich Ihnen mal zeigen.
Ich nehme noch Visoprolol, da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Dann ist hier noch drauf HCT 12,5. Ich weiß gar nicht wofür das ist.
Ich nehme das auch morgens.
Bei wie viel können Sie wiederholen?
HCT heißt das.
HCT, okay.
12,5 und dann hat mir mein Arzt noch Lysinogrel verschrieben, das nehme ich auch morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch was abend, das ist Atorvastatin.
Okay, wie viel mir nehmen Sie Atorvastatin?
Da steht 20 und das muss ich dann abend nehmen.
Okay, abends.
Frau Böker, wo sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, vor 10 Jahren schon. Da habe ich ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen auf der rechten Seite.
Rechtsseite, ja.
Ja, sonst würde ich glaube ich meine Treppen gar nicht mehr hochkommen.
Ich verstehe das und haben Sie schon Allergie oder Falschrecken?
Ja, also was ich gar nicht vertragen kann, das ist Hausstaub.
Also so Hausstaubmilben, da kriege ich so eine üble Schnupfnase,
deswegen muss ich bei mir immer gründlich saugen und sauber machen und so.
Und so meine Sofas und muss ich alles immer gut absaugen.
Super, Frau Böker, sind Sie Raucherin oder haben Sie schon geraucht?
Früher habe ich geraucht, aber vor sechs Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Ja, damit der Bauchspeicheldrüse war.
Da hatte ich dann wirklich so Probleme, dass ich dann gesagt habe,
nee, also jetzt musst du das mal aufhören.
Aber ich habe nie so furchtbar viel geraucht.
Okay, wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Oh, ich habe mit 18 angefangen und bis vor sechs Jahren.
Also da war ich auch im Blick, da war ich 58, da habe ich 40 Jahre.
Aber ich habe immer nur so ein halbes Päckchen geraucht,
mehr als zehn habe ich nie geraucht.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke abends sehr gerne ein Glas Bier.
Jede Abend.
Oder zwei, drei Gläser Bier trinke ich schon jeden Abend.
Es ist so viel.
Aber das tut gut, da kann man gut schlafen und ich trinke auch immer,
das ist gut für die Nieren.
Ich verstehe das. Und konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, damit haben unsere Generationen hatte,
mit auch nichts zu tun.
Frau Böker, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, nein, nein. Also mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Meine Mutter ist schon sehr, sehr alt.
Die ist eigentlich erstaunlich gesund, aber mein Vater ist mit 80 gestorben.
Woran gestorben, Ihrer Vater?
Ja, also was dann tatsächlich das Ende verursacht hat, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich weiß, dass der große Beschwerden hatte,
der hatte Knochenkrebs.
Und dann hatte der furchtbare Schmerzen und dann hatte er starke Schmerzmittel bekommen.
Das ist so verlassen für Sie.
Und welche Erkrankungen hat Ihre Mutter?
Ja, also wie gesagt, die ist eigentlich ziemlich fit.
Die hatte dann so, als sie ungefähr so alt war wie ich,
da hatte die mal so eine Unterleibsoperation.
Da hat man ihr glaube ich die Gebärmutter und die Eierstücke rausgemacht,
weil da irgendwas war.
Aber danach ist die eigentlich, hat die sich gut wieder erholt.
Okay, super. Und Frau Böker, Sie ist verheiratet.
Ich bin verwirrt, schon lange.
Ich musste schon lange für meine Kinder alleine sorgen.
Okay, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Die sind natürlich erwachsen.
Okay, und was machen Sie als Beruflich?
Oder sind Sie schon Wendnerin?
Ich bin ja, ich bin früh in Rente gegangen.
Nach dieser Bauchspeicheldrüsen-Geschichte.
Und als es mit dem Knie und eins zum anderen kam,
da bin ich ein bisschen früher in Rente gegangen.
Okay, früher, was beschäftigen Sie?
Ich war Hausmeisterin.
Okay.
Ja, das war auch viel mit Saubermachen und Schlüsselversorgen.
Und um Leute zu kommen, ja, das war viel.
Ich komme gleich, Frau Böker.
Laut Ihrer Bescheidung verdachte ich auch eine Lungenentzündung.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst möchte ich Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen vornehmen.
Und auch Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Danach, wenn Ihre Befunde vorliegen, bespreche ich mit meinem Oberarzt.
Und ich erkläre Ihnen alles, Schritt für Schritt, bis es weitergeht.
Das klingt doch gut, ja.
Okay.
Ja.
Aber Frau Böker, das ist nicht so ein Kenntnisverfall für mich, für Düsseldorf.
Wieso?
Ja, das ist so ein anderes Fall für mich.
Ich meine, das ist sogar ein Düsseldorfer Fall.
Ich habe das erste Mal gehört.
Aber wir sind ja auch noch nicht am Ende.
Entschuldigung.
Alles gut.
Aber möchte von den Kollegen vielleicht noch jemand zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Nichts?
Hallo?
Frau Böker, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, eine gestaute Halsschlagade oder irgendetwas?
Dass die Halsschlagade irgendwie dick ist?
Da habe ich so viel Speck, das kann ich gar nicht sehen.
Entschuldigung.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie bevor erkältet, zum Beispiel, ein oder zwei Wochen?
Ob ich erkältet war?
Habe ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig.
Nein, ich war jetzt lange nicht erkältet.
Danke schön.
Frau Böker, waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Die Reiseanwendung wurde nicht gefragt.
Ja, richtig wurde nicht gefragt.
Aber nein, ich habe gar kein Geld, um ins Ausland zu fahren.
Also Urlaub kann ich mir gar nicht gut leisten.
Und gehen Sie öfter in die Nacht beim Wasser lassen?
Ja, ein bis zwei Mal in der Nacht muss ich auf alle Fälle auf die Toilette.
Hat sie aber auch gefragt.
Einfach eine letzte Frage stellen.
Natürlich.
Ist Ihnen eine blauliche Lippen aufgefallen?
Nein, aber ich gucke auch nicht so oft ins Spiegel.
Also ich wüsste jetzt, nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Frau Doktor, wollen Sie loslegen oder brauchen Sie noch ein paar Minuten?
Ja, wir können los.
Wir kommen zusammen auf die Pferde.
Werden Sie sehen.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Mein Name ist Fatima Kübra-Aildiz.
Ich habe heute neue Patienten aufgenommen.
Es geht um Frau Hilde Berger.
Sie ist 64-jährige Patientin, geboren am 12.07.1982.
Sie ist 64.
Sie ist 84 Kilo.
Sie wiegt 84 Kilo, ne?
Ja.
Sie wiegt 84 Kilo.
Sie ist 1,64 Meter groß.
Oh ja.
Frau Berger stellt sich bei uns wegen seit zwei Monaten bestehender Disziplin und enger Gefühl vor.
Sie berichtet, dass die Disziplin langsam aufgetreten und belastungabhängig ist.
Aber momentan ist sie beschwerdefrei.
Wenn sie bei Ihnen sitzt.
Ja, bei Ihnen sitzen sie beschwerdefrei.
Als verstärksten Faktoren berichtet sie, hinlegen, Treppe steigen und Tüte bringen.
Tüte bringen?
Ja, mit Kauftauschen bringen.
Eine schwere Einkaufstasche, wenn sie schwer zu tragen hat.
Ja, schwer zu tragen.
Und auch beim Hinlegen.
Für Lindeitfaktoren erwähnt sie, mit zwei Kissen zu schlafen.
Sie schläft mit zwei Kissen, dann kann sie besser schlafen.
Ja.
Sie begleitet über Nukterie und 3 Kilo Zunahme.
Gewichtszunahme, ja.
Gewichtszunahme und schwindelig.
Und auch geschwollene, gerötete Beine, beide Seiten.
Und seit vier Wochen, wenn sie Probleme haben.
Als vegetative Anamnese ergaben sich, ja, Schwitzen, Müdigkeit, in Sonne und trockene Hüsten, morgens trockene Hüsten auch.
Ja, eine genekologische Anamnese war unauffällig.
Sie leidet an arterieller Hypotonie seit fünf Jahren.
Und auch Hypoalipidemie und auch Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Sie hat eine Fremde Mannheit und sie erlitt vor sieben Jahren Pancreatitis.
Bei der Medikamentanamnese erwähnt sie eine Name von Isoprolol einmal morgens, HCT515 einmal morgens, Markumalhalbetabletze einmal abends, Isonipril einmal morgens und Atorvastatin 20 mg einmal abends.
Bei der Voroperationenanamnese ergaben sich lediglich vor zehn Jahren rechte, rechte,
ja, Entschuldigung, rechte Arthroplastiknie, Gelenkarthroplastik.
Ok, ja.
Und als bekannte Allergie ist Hausstoff. Sie reagiert darauf Rhinoconjunktivitis.
Sie ist Extra-Rin, aber sie hat 20 Packung Jahre Zigaretten vorgeschickt.
Und jede abends ein Fleischer Bier getrinkt.
Trinkt sie.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Als familiäre Anamnese erwähnte er lediglich bei der Vater mit sechstischem Lebensjahr Knochenkrebs verstorben.
Als soziale Anamnistisch ist sie verlebt.
Für was?
Sie ist nicht verheiratet, nicht geschwitzen, aber verwitwet.
Sie ist schon Rentnerin wegen Pankreatitis vorgeschichtet, aber früher als Hausmeisterin gearbeitet.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Herzinsuffizienz.
Was könnte es noch Differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Differenzialdiagnostisch ist akutes Coronasendrom und Pulmonarenboli in Betracht.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Um meine Differenzialdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst diese Patientenkörperliche Untersuchungen vornehmen.
Mit der Karmete überwachen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich achte darauf, dass die Beine ödämisch mit dem Finger kontrolliert werden.
Und auch die Herz-Oskillation, das ich erwarte ein paar Probleme.
Und auch Lungenödeme erwarte ich beim Lungenabhören.
Okay, ja.
Und auch, ich werde für diese Patienten natürlich Echokardiographie und Rangenthorax.
Aber gegebenenfalls, ich weiß es nicht, aber Spirometrie.
Das wäre auch noch eine Idee, ja. Und was machen Sie noch?
Und auch CT, Angio oder?
Ja, Laborwerte brauchen wir ja noch.
Ja, natürlich. Das Blutbild, die einzelnen Parameter, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Elektrolyte, Herzmuskelensime, Gerinnungsparameter, Blutgasanalyse, DITIMA.
Ja, gut. Also komplett einmal, ja. Gut.
Ja.
Gut. Wenn sich Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose auf eine Herzinsuffizienz bestätigt, was wäre denn dann der Patientin für eine Therapie?
Was würde man für eine Therapie anwenden?
Ich würde diese Patienten stationärer aufnehmen und die Urethike verordnen und engmenschige Kontrolle, wie viel Urinmengen hat und...
Ah, Flüssigkeit belastieren.
... wie es geht. Und auch kardiologisches Konstil anfordern.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und auch natürlich kardioproduktive Medikamente, alternative nutzen.
Ah, gucken, ja. Gucken, ob man da was ändert. Das müssten dann die Kardiologen praktisch einabstimmen, ja.
Ja.
Ja, okay, gut. Ja, vielen Dank. Lassen Sie mich wissen, was jetzt die Ergebnisse bringen, ob Ihre Diagnose sich bestätigt, ja?
Gut. Wir können gleich zur Kritik übergehen. Ja, das ist natürlich richtig klar. Hat die eine Herzinsuffizienz, ne?
Und als Differentialdiagnose hatten Sie, das fand ich gut, die Pulmonalhypertonie genannt. Die Lungenembolie, weiß ich nicht, haben Sie die auch gehabt?
Ja, gut. Und, ja, irgendjemand hat noch mal COPD gesagt, weiß ich nicht, wie wahrscheinlich das ist. Ich finde, das passt eigentlich nicht so gut. Aber gut, ja.
Ja, was, also eigentlich haben Sie schön gefragt. Sie haben nett mit der Patientin geredet. Sie haben sie immer schön mit Namen angesprochen, sehr schön.
Heute konnte ich Sie auch gut verstehen eigentlich und wir haben wenig Probleme gehabt in der Verständigung so.
Ein paar Sachen gab es. Da haben Sie aber noch mal ganz schnell korrigiert. Auf den Blick, was war das, beim Geburtsjahr, da waren Sie erst bei 82 und dann haben Sie aber noch mal schnell korrigiert.
Ja, 62 ist richtig. Packages haben Sie richtig ausgerechnet und, ja, das war ein, denke ich, Hörfehler oder so. Der Vater ist nicht mit 60 verstorben, sondern mit 80.
Dann, ja, Anamnese, würde ich sagen, war durchgehend ziemlich gut. Sie machen ein paar kleine grammatikalische Formulierungsfehler, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie nichts ganz brüchig Beaufregendes.
Ja, ich habe zwischendurch, glaube ich, einmal nachgehakt und gefragt, aber grundsätzlich war das sehr okay und Sie haben auch sehr schön systematisch gefragt.
Manchmal haben Sie heute nicht reagiert auf das, was Sie Ihnen schon erzählt hatten. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, was das war. Genau, mit der Nuktorie zum Beispiel, da haben Sie nochmal nachgefragt, obwohl Sie das vorher schon gesagt hatten.
Und ich meine noch irgendwas war da, ach ja, mit dem Schwindeln, genau, das hatte Sie Ihnen vorher schon erzählt, dass Sie sich am Geländer festhalten muss oder so.
Und da haben Sie nochmal gefragt, war Sie ohnmächtig oder war Ihnen schwindelig? Und ja, das ist halt nett, wenn man das praktisch respektiert, dass Sie es schon gesagt hat und das registriert, dass Sie es schon gesagt hat.
Gut, dann, ja, was ich schön fand dann in Ihrer Präsentation bei der Oberärztin, haben Sie eigentlich auch ziemlich vollständig berichtet. Sie haben einen guten Anfangssatz gehabt, stellte sich hohe Wege.
Was man natürlich sagen kann, wenn die gute Frau als 64 ist und 84 Kilo wiegt, dann ist die schon adipös. Könnte man erwähnen, weiß ich nicht, also übergewichtiger Ernährungszustand, weiß ich nicht.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie haben zwar kurz, jetzt bin ich, Entschuldigung, nochmal bei der Anamnese, Sie haben nach Allergie gefragt, da hat sie die Hausdopmlung angegeben.
Da haben Sie aber nicht weiter gefragt, gibt es sonst noch irgendwas? Sie hätte sonst nämlich noch eine Penicillinallergie auf dem Zettel gehabt, ja, aber haben Sie gar nicht gefragt.
Und eine Sache, die Sie auch nicht gefragt haben, das hat mich auch gewundert, dass keiner gefragt hat, heutzutage in aller Munde Impfungen haben Sie nicht abgefragt.
Das sollten Sie für die Prüfung auf alle Fälle als feste Frage auf dem Zettel haben.
Gut, dann nochmal im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, haben Sie eigentlich schön jetzt Fachterminologie verwendet, das fand ich gut.
Bei der Knie-Tap weiß ich nicht, ob das irgendjemand verstanden hat, haben Sie Atro?
Atroplastie, ja.
Ob man das tatsächlich...
Omatroplastie, ja.
Ich glaube, heute sagen die alle Knie-Tap, also ich weiß es aber nicht.
Vielleicht ist es, ich musste tatsächlich immer überlegen, wie könnte man das denn, wie Sie so gezögert haben, wie heißt denn das, war mir jetzt nicht klar.
Was Sie nicht so, finde ich, nicht so realistisch geschildert haben, wie es die Patientin Ihnen eigentlich erzählt hat, ist die Geschichte mit dem Schwitzen.
Das hat Sie ja eigentlich so ein bisschen bagatellisiert.
Sie hat ja gesagt, na ja, es war ja heiß und meine Wohnung ist warm und ich wohne ziemlich weit oben, da ist es halt heiß.
Und da haben Sie gesagt, dass sie halt schwitzt und eigentlich tut sie das aber ja normalerweise nicht.
Würde ich jetzt sagen, das ist eher so tatsächlich den äußeren Umständen geschuldet.
Aber klar haben Sie gesagt, ja, die Beschwerden sind belastungabhängig, das war noch ein wichtiger Punkt.
Und ja, da haben Sie sich schwergetan mit der ganz banalen Geschichte, dass sie eine schwere Tasche trägt, eine schwere Einkaufs-Tasche, die Treppe hochträgt.
Also schwerer Wäschekorb, irgendwas schweres tragen und Treppe hochgehen.
Das ist halt wirklich, zumal wenn es dann warm ist oder so, kennen wir das eigentlich alle.
Ja, dass das ein bisschen anstrengend ist, aber bei ihr ist es halt so, dass sie da Luft nötig ist und das Gefühl hat, dass es ihr nicht gut geht.
Und das haben Sie nicht so schön geschildert mit dieser Belastungsabhängigkeit.
Und ja, Sie haben dann gesagt, ja, was ist erleichternd?
Ja, sie schläft mit zwei Kissen, also flaches Liegen kann sie nicht hinlegen.
Ist ja eigentlich immer gut, wenn man schlapp ist und müde ist, geht es einem eigentlich immer besser.
Aber flaches Liegen ging halt bei ihr nicht, weil sie dann eben das Gefühl hatte, kriegt sie keine Luft.
Also flaches Liegen geht nicht gut, aber deshalb schläft sie seit einiger Zeit mit zwei Kopfkissen.
Ja, dann haben Sie erwähnt genau die entscheidenden, ja, so eigentlich wohl, wo der Pfad klar war.
Die Uedema haben Sie erwähnt, die Gewichtszunahme haben Sie erwähnt.
Und die Belastungsdyspnoe eigentlich schon klar.
Und sie hat ja tatsächlich angegeben, dass ihr Hausarzt vor einem halben Jahr vor Flimmer diagnostiziert hat.
Deswegen kriegt sie mal Kummer.
Also kann man da schon sagen, ja, das Herz müssen wir uns angucken.
Das ist schon klar. Gut, ja, also es ist tatsächlich die globale Herzenssuffizienz.
Das ist keine Frage. Und da haben Sie die ganze schöne Diagnostik, haben Sie eigentlich auch perfekt aufgeführt, was Sie machen würden.
Ja, ein paar Sachen kamen hier von den Kollegen.
Zum Beispiel die Dehymere kamen und ja, die Halsvenenstauung, das kam auch noch.
Das hat, glaube ich, noch ein Kollege in der Frage, in den Fragen danach erwähnt, ob ihr aufgefallen ist, dass die Halsvenen dicker sind.
Da hat sie ja gesagt, mein Hals ist so dick, das sieht man nicht.
Ja, also das wäre vielleicht noch ein Punkt gewesen.
Ja, das war es eigentlich.
Diagnostik klar, stationäre Aufnahme, cardiologisch, Konsü, klar.
Und ja, vielleicht Änderungen, Lebensstile, könnte man noch erwähnen, dass sie vielleicht tatsächlich ein bisschen Gewicht reduziert.
Oder auch, dass sie vielleicht eben ganz moderates Training macht.
Unter Anleitung Herzsport, Rehersport, das soll ja auch im höheren Alter noch was bringen.
Ja, gut.